[Music]
hey red we're not gonna get away with
this are we
[Music]
Paul a dead man a weapon a dress torn
and discarded on the ground transistor
begins with remarkable confidence
throwing you right into the life of
nightclub singer red at what might be
her lowest point there's no immediate
explanation for who she is or what this
world is or what happened the night
before and all this mystery only makes
your journey more captivating transistor
asks you to trust in it just to come
along on the journey even though you
have no idea where you're going and it
rewards your trust leaving a beautiful
and unconventional sci-fi tale with a
human heart and empowering you with a
wonderfully flexible combat system that
fuses real-time and turn-based action to
create something that feels unique
[Music]
[Music]
as you move through cloudbank the world
of transistor you encounter
manifestations of this process a force
that's seemingly running rampant
annihilate including as it goes with the
help of the transistor the strange
weapon you pull from a dead man's body
when the game begins you fight the
process you can run around fighting your
enemies in real time but you're
outnumbered and you're just not quick
enough or strong enough to overcome in
this way thankfully you have a trick up
your sleeve called turn which enables
you to freeze time plot out a sequence
of attacks and then carry them out in
rapid succession as you progress you
collect more and more techniques called
functions each one the essence of a
fallen resident of cloudbank each
technique can be used as an active
ability or to upgrade another technique
or to give you a passive benefit there's
a remarkable variety of ways in which
these techniques can be combined and
hitting on particularly effective
combinations and putting them to use in
battle is immensely satisfying
transistors combat makes you feel
powerful by giving you an edge on the
process but it also encourages you to
think carefully about what you're doing
because the process is no pushover
it has tricks of its own sometimes
obscuring your vision sometimes pulling
you out of you're turning things without
warning it's a clever foe which makes
matching wits with it all the more
enjoyable
[Applause]
but what is the process really and
what's happened to all the residents of
cloud bangers red is driven to get to
the bottom of it and she's not alone
from inside the transistor speaks a
voice who it belongs to is not
immediately clear but his voice brings
life to your quest as he responds to
your actions and slowly helps you piece
together the story of cloud Bank also
shedding light on the world and its
people are the files accompanying each
function to reveal more about these
people whose essence has been trapped in
the transistor you have to use their
functions in different ways putting them
in active slots upgrade slots and
passive slots giving you an incentive to
tweak your build and try different
techniques the files are so well written
and paint such vivid pictures of cloud
banks falling residents that you
naturally want to uncover all the
details they have to tell you I never
had a chance to introduce myself
what slowly emerges in transistor is a
story of a clandestine organization
called the Camerata working behind the
scenes in cloud bank for its own
purposes and while the answers to the
plots questions about who the Camerata
are and what the transistor does are
interesting they're not what makes
transistors story special cloudbank is a
technological world but not a cold one
it's not a place of pure ones and zeros
there's a touch of magic even of
spirituality two transistors story a
sense that there are things within the
world of cloudbank that transcend our
understanding of what's possible and
transistors artful presentation has a
magic of its own there are a few
astounding moments and transistor
moments when the music sweeps it and
carries you away when the visuals frame
the action in an exhilarating way as in
an early moment when red silhouetted
against the city speeds across cloud
bank on a motorcycle hunting the people
who are responsible for everything
that's happened
do me a favor
don't let me go so yes transistor is a
fun action role-playing game with a neat
combat system but beautiful moments like
this one make it more than that they
make it a game with a soul